نحو 300 مليون عامل بدوام كامل في كافه
القطاعات حول العالم معرضون لخطر فقدان
وظيفتهم والسبب هنا هو الذكاء الاصطناعي
ولهذا الامر ثمن سيؤدي طبعا الى اضطراب
كبير في سوق العمل وفق ما كشفه تقرير
لمصرف جولد من ساكس الذي اوضح بان ربع
العمل المنجز في الولايات المتحده وفي
منطقه اليورو يمكن جعله اليا بفضل التقدم
الكبير في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي مثل تشات
جي بي تي وغير من هذه التطبيقات هذا
المشهد يمكن ان يؤدي الى طفره انتاجيه من
شانها زياده الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
العالمي السنوي بالنسبه 7% على مدى العشر
سنوات المقبله الارقام كشفت هنا ايضا
مشاهدينا بان ثلثي الوظائف في الولايات
المتحده واوروبا معرضه لدرجه معينه من
تحولها الى اليه جراء طبعا الذكاء الاصط
والمحامون والموظفون الاداريون من بين
اولئك الاكثر عرضه لخطر الاستغناء عن بعض
مهامهم نحو سبعه بالمئه من العاملين في
الولايات المتحده يعملون في وظائف يمكن
انجاز نصف مهامهم فيها على الاقل بواسطه
الذكاء الاصطناعي وهم عرضه للاستبدال طبعا
والابحاث مماثله بالنسبه لاوروبا في
المقابل تحدثت صحيفه واشنطن بوست في وقت
سابق هذا الاسبوع ان الذكاء الاصطناعي لم
يحتل الوظائف بعد واوضحت ان الذكاء
الاصطناعي يشق الطريق بشكل متزايد عبر
الصناعات المختلفه ويغير طبعا شكل ومضمون
الوظائف بدايه من الطب مرورا بالبيع
بالتجزئه حتى التسويق والكتابه
[موسيقى]